So, where should we start from?
We need to still fix a few questions, especially
the colors of some walls.
Because as we said, you know, we would like
to have a mix of colors.
We want in some very important places of the
exhibition to keep the MoMA standard white,
because there are some places where you need
to be a little more contemplative.
I think here in that section around the conceptual
series of the late '60s, early '70s, to have
something that would be a different nuance
of grays.
Or something that would be pure white and
then some very poppish colors.
Red, yellow, green, blue.
We haven't gotten there yet, but we're trying.
We're trying to do something that's a little
bit outside of the standard grays that we
typically go for, so...which will be nice.
I think it's tough to nail it exactly.
Yeah.
It's tough to nail it, because Stephen is a
color photographer, and so we already have
a lot of colors in the show.
And that, in fact, was one of my concerns.
That's in fact what I think maybe we should
discuss today.
Bradley.
Hi.
Nice to meet you.
I'm Peter.
Hi, Peter.
Steven.
My name's Steven too.
Hi.
I'll remember that.
You're right in time.
Right in time.
American Surfaces
Have I ever identified any of these people
for you?
Have I ever identified them to you?
No.
No, no.
So, this is P. Evan Sydney, who...
This I remember.
And...
This also.
Henry Geldzahler
This also. this also.
And this is Tony Hiss, whose father is Alger
Hiss.
And you have Alger's Hiss widow somewhere.
Yes.
Second row.
And that's my mother.
This...
No self-portraits in American Surfaces?
No.
I missed that one.
I hit all of the...what would become the Instagram
themes, but I missed the selfie.
You got the food, you got pets.
In fact, silly pet pictures.
Silly pet pictures.
I don't know if toilets have taken off on
Instagram.
No, they haven't.
The way that you enjoyed them, but...
I noticed you were a little discreet and said
that I photographed toilet seats.
But the toilets seats were in fact attached
to commodes.
See that’s a panda, and that's panda lunch,
so I think the pictures were taken at the
same time.
Let me find the panda.
That one is flight to New York, flight to
St. John in November of the same year.
Okay.
And this one?
No, not that one.
Where is the one with...
Oh, there's a...
That's DC, November, and this one is DC...
So I made two trips to do pandas?
I don't remember two trips.
Oh, look at that, it's great.
So, it's eight seconds.
I know that you found it a little too slow,
but I like it like that.
What's these yellow marks?
No.
That's normal.
That's just the tape that they put...
Oh, that's on the wall?
Yeah.
That's on the wall.
That's the tape that they put.
And I think they want it to stay there.
I don't know why, but they want it to check
for a few...
If you want it faster, of course, we can,
but I would not change it.
This looks okay.
This is where the
Stupid little books
The Instagram
Oh, the Instagram or the iPads?
The iPads.
Okay.
So that you will have five iPads here on their
pedestals.
Maybe we will have a space where people can
have a look at the catalogue I'm not sure.
And then you will have the book suspending
from the ceiling.
Oh, great.
Yeah I’ve made the same decisions, I'm not
sure I would have made the same decisions.
But I thought about it more, I thought
I would have done a much more conservative
show, much more traditional show and a much
more traditional book, not because I thought
it would be better, it's because I wouldn't
have thought of it.
I wouldn't have conceived of this.
I wouldn't have conceived of the book.
That's why...
That's why curators are.
That's why curators are curators.
That’s the same with all the books I do.
If I have a new editor, I say, I want you
to be very active, come up with a...help me
come with a concept for the book, because
you think this is what you do and you have
more imagination than I do about it.
This is going to be a really good gallery.
One, first.
That's a good start.
So you said it's gonna be three floors?
Three levels.
Begins on the ground floor and goes down to the Titus...
Wow...
Towards the lobby into the club.
It's like going into the club, stepping down
those steps into the club.
That's the idea.
That sounds like my sex life.
Every day of three years condensed into one...
Five years, even.
Yeah, five?
Yeah, yeah, five years.
Wow.
Klaus would be very impressed.
Klaus would be...he would want to put his
10 cents into it, like "No, let me check,
the image and..." you know.
But he would...of course, he'd be very impressed,
and of course he probably also would want
to make pies and cakes.
Yeah, he could cater the opening.
You imagine?
Yeah.
He would have definitely cooked his ass off
and catered the whole event.
Okay.
Get ready for one hell of a locker.
Let's see what's in here.
That's a hopsack dress.
Oh this goes on and on.
Who cares about Toledo?
My dad's suit, suits.
I used to travel with this until they banned
big suitcases.
Oh, that can't be it.
No.
See, it's all this stuff, it's like...
What the hell is all this?
Okay.
That's one.
That's a...no, this is a wig.
So these are all wigs.
All right.
Is it likely to be in suitcase like that as
opposed to...
You know what?
I don't remember if it's in a box, something,
down here.
Another crazy thing.
Is it going to be on a coat hanger?
No, no, no, no.
It's going to be in a box or another suitcase.
There's two more black cases, right?
What does that say there?
And this is from California, so...
Oh, maybe.
Okay.
The cape of Klaus Nomi.
That’s it.
That's it?
That's it.
Hold it up to the light, there it is.
Hold it up to the light, Joey.
You can see through the plastic.
Yeah, that's it.
Oh my gosh.
The plastic cape.
I got a lot of Nomi costumes in here, tons
of Nomi stuff that no one has ever seen before.
It's like the head dresses and I got the wigs
that Klaus wore, whatever that...so it's all
in here.
And we've been pestering Joey to dig this
out, to get into this closet.
For about a year.
We've been trying to get into this closet
for a year.
We finally got into Joey's closet.
Right.
And I was, like, not going to do it.
I was like, you know what, okay, we're getting
close to this.
It's going to happen, it's not going to happen,
so here it is and I'm glad it did.
And this is the way to do it.
Right, exactly.
Do it together.
With the whole crew.
Yeah.
This is a job.
All right.
Shall we start repacking?
Watch your fingers.
Straight ahead.
Superb.
Ready?
We got everything we want?
Yes.
Okay.